شكرا لك طاهر اذا المشاهدين الكرام
مستمرون معكم في تغطيه وقائع هذا الزلزال
الكبير الذي ضرب المنطقه الحدوديه بين
تركيا وسوريا الحصيله هي طبعا ما يتم
التركيز عليه الان في المجمل المشاهدين
لدينا 3700 قتيل حتى الان جراء هذا
الزلزال في كل من تركيا وسوريا وتفصيلا
لاعداد الضحايا اخر حصيله في تركيا بلغت
عشره قتيلا واكثر من 13 الف اصابه اذا
بحسب اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه فيما
سجل تدمير اكثر من خمسه الاف
وستمئه مبنى وتشهد المستشفيات في تركيا
مشاهدينا ضغوطا بسبب كثره اعداد المصابين
اذا هذا في تركيا اما في سوريا فقد ارتفعت
الاصيله الى
1371 قتيلا ولا احصائيات دقيقه حتى اللحظه
لعدد الاصابات بسبب اذا بحسب المصادر طبعا
وبسبب ان هناك مناطق خاضعه لسيطره النظام
ومناطق اخرى خاضعه لسيطره المعارضه وهناك
مناطق يصعب الوصول اليها ما يعمق من
الازمه الانسانيه هناك وعلى ذكر سوريا اذا
الصور التي نشاهد الان مشاهدينا هي من حلب
حلب اذن التي تضررت بشكل كبير من جراء هذا
الزلزال او بالاحرى نتحدث عن سلسله زلازل
وتم رصده اكثر من 200 زلزال في عقاب
الزلزالين القويين الاول كان
بسبعه فاصل ثماني درجات على سلم ريختر في
ساعات الفجر تلاهوا بعد ساعات زلزال اخر
قويه
على بسبع درجات فاصل خمسه على مقياس ريختر
وهو ما احدث دمار هائلا طبعا
واستمرت بعده سلسله من الهزات الارتداديه
اذا المشاهدين نتابع معكم صور الركام يعني
التي تتكرر منذ ساعات الصباح
مره اخرى اذا في حلب التي انهارت فيها
العديد من المباني نستمع قليلا للصوت
الطبيعي مع استمرار جهود الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام كما تتابعون صور
لاستمرار عمليات الانقاذ في حلب في سوريا
حتى الان الحصيله
3700 قتيل جراء هذا الزلزال في كل من
تركيا وسوريا ولكن الصحه العالميه الان
ترسم صوره متشائمه بان هذه الحصيله قد
تتضاعف ثماني مرات اذا بالنظر الى الدمار
الكبير شاهدوا الان هذه الجرافات هذه
الجرافات تحاول ان يعني تبعد الركام قليلا
لعل وعسى يكون هناك انتشال
لناجين من تحت هذا الركام او يعني انتشال
الضحايا الذين فارقوا الحياه جراء انهيار
عليهم
[موسيقى]
بس الله هيك نحن نايمين شغل رب العالمين
هذا هون
[موسيقى]
والله
[ضحك]
وجع قلبي
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا طبعا هي
مقاس تتكرر على مدار هذا اليوم الحصيله
حتى الان 3700 قتيل في كل من تركيا وسوريا
جراء هذا الزلزال منظمه الصحه العالميه
تتوقع ان يتضاعف هذا الرقم ثمانيه اضعاف
في اخر الاخبار العجله الان وزاره الدفاع
البلجيكيه تؤكد بانها وضع الطائره
العسكريه مجهزه تحت تصرف تركيا لنقل فرق
الاغاثه افادت وكاله الانباء السعوديه بان
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
قدم التعازي هاتفيا لرئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان في ضحايا الزلزال الامير محمد بن
سلمان اكد وقوف السعوديه ومساندتها لتركيا
لتجاوز هذه الكارثات الطبيعيه بدوره اعرب
اردوغان عن تقديره
لموقف السعوديه
ووقوفها الى جانب تركيا في هذا الظرف
الصعب
السلطات الرومانيه اعلنت كذلك ارسال وحده
انقاذ الى تركيا للمساعده في عمليات
الاغاثه جراء تداعيه الزلزال وتتضمن الفرق
تلك عشرات من المختصين بالانقاذ وعددا من
الكلاب المدربه على البحث تحت الانقاض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
امال يا مره
قال رئيس برنامج الغذاء العالمي ان فرق
الطوارئ التابعه للبرنامج تستعد لتقديم
المساعده اذا اقتضت الضروره بعد الزلزال
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا قدم عبر حسابه على
تويتر تعزيه لعائلته ضحايا الزلزال
نتابع ايضا من اسطنبول مع مراسل العربيه
زيدان زنكلو زيدان اهلا بك معنا استمعنا
قبل قليل المؤتمر الصحفي لنائب الرئيس
التركي اذا الحصيله في ارتفاع اضافه الى
ذلك ابرز ما قاله المسؤول التركي
نعم لا شك ان الحصيله مع الاسف في ارتفاع
مستمر نتيجه وصول طرق او زياره عدد فرق
الانقاذ وبالتالي الوصول الى مناطق متضرره
صهيب اكثر والعثور على سواء كان ناجين او
حتى ضحايا اكثر
طبعا من المرجح ارتفاع الاعداد بشكل اكبر
من ذلك بكثير وفقا للمعطيات التي شاهدناها
وصمناها
وحديثنا مع سكان يعيشون في تلك المناطق في
جنوب تركيا بالعموم اعيد الاحصائيه
الرسميه التي تحدث عنها نائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد اوكساي عدد القتلى وصل الى
2379 شخصا وحوالي او
14,43
جريحا جراء الزلزال طبعا
النائب الرئيس التركي تحدث ايضا عن انقاذ
7,840 شخصا من تحت الانقاب حتى الان في
الولايات العشر من قبل فرق
الانقاذ طبعا فيما يخص فرق الانقاذ مدير
افاد مدير الهيئه هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد تحدث عن ان
51,300 متطوع جديد انضموا الى افاد
للمساهمه في انقاذ ضحايا الزلازل طبعا
معظم هؤلاء هم من المتطوعين والناشطين
الاتراك الذين انضموا الى فرق الاله هيئه
او كوادر هيئه
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه عمليات الانقاذ
ما زالت تستمر وطبعا ترقب تركي
لوصول قوافل المساعدات ونتحدث تحديدا في
كلمه المساعدات طرق الانقاذ والتواقم
الطبيه والمساعدات الطبيه التي تحتاجها
تركيا الان بشكل عاجل وسريع جدا
نعم عمليات البحث والوصول لمزيد من
الناجين تحت الانقاض نعم زيدان طبعا
المنطقه تمر بمنخفض جوي شديد البروده في
هذه المرحله هذا سيصعب من عمليات الانقاذ
كذلك بسبب طبعا الزلزال والزلازل والهزات
الارتداديه هناك انقطاع ربما في التيار
الكهربائي وهناك خوف كذلك من الاقتراب من
هذه البنايات التي تتداعى او المتصدعه الى
اي حد يعني كل هذه الظروف تؤثر على عمليات
الانقاذ
نعم لا شك ان الهزات الاعتداديه يعني في
الساعه الماضيه كان هناك ذات ارتداديه
خلال الساعه الماضيه كان هناك ذات
ارتداديه في ولايات كهرمان مرعش في ملاطيا
في اضيمن في كهرمان مرعش كانت الهزه
الاقتصاديه بلغت شدتها على مقياسر 5.4 ما
اثرت ايضا الرعب والهلع سواء في بين
السكان او حتى بين طواقم الموجوده هناك كل
هذه العوامل اضافه للسقف السيء جدا
صهيب كل هذه العوامل تؤثر سلبا على سير
عمليات الانقاذ مع الاسف موجه الموجه
الهوائيه البارده ستستمر خلال الايام
القادمه الحراره مثلا في غازي عنتاب الان
خمس درجات تحت الصفر او ربما اكثر في
كهرمان مرعش اقل من ذلك ايضا كونكر امام
مرعش منطقه جبليه بارده قرب جبال طوروس
يعني هذه الظروف الطبيعيه بالاضافه الى
الاضرار الكبيره التي خلفها الزلزال
وانقطاع بعض الطرق اضافه الى
تعطل او انفجار بعض المحولات الكهربائيه
وايضا شبكات البث
لشبكات الهاتف المحمول ابراج البث عفوا
لشبكات الهاتف محمود وايضا انابيب الغاز
كل هذه عوامل تؤثر سلبا على
اولا الطواقم الطبيه وايضا على المنكوبين
الذين بقوا في العراء دون ماوى نعم كنت
اسالك عن هؤلاء زيدان
نائب رئيس تركي تحدث عن مساله ايواء
الناجين هناك ولكن كنت تحدثتني في ساعه
سابقه ضمن هذه التغطيه بان الناس خائفه
يعني هناك من يفضل البيع ان يبيت في
العراء في هذا الجو البارد في هذا الصقيع
على ان يكون في مكان مغطى ربما بسبب
الصدمه لا مازال هلا هلا شرحت لي كذلك
الموقف بالنسبه لهذه الليله الاولى بعد
الزلزال
نعم بدايه سانطلق في هذه النقطه من تصيح
أخوان رئيس تركيا عندما قال ان تقريبا
مراكز اللواء استوعبت اثنان
الشخص في هذه المراكز لكن بالعموم في هذا
الجو المشحون بالخوف والترقب والقلق
الاشاعات
واحيانا وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وما ينشر
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يزيد من حاله
الرعب والقلق لدى
السكان وهناك اقاويل واشاعات كثيره تنتشر
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي عن زلزال او
هزاز قويه ربما تصيب بعض المناطق هذه
الولايه او تلك لذلك هذا يدفع بالمزيد من
السكان لتفضيل البقاء في الاماكن المكشوفه
في الحدائق في على ارصفه الطرقات او في
المنصفات في الطرقات او في اماكن بعيده
حتى عن السكن لا اذا خارج المدن مع وجود
اطفال وكبار في السن واذا تحدثنا ايضا على
ان معظم الذين فروا فروا بابسط اللباس
الذي كانوا يرتدونه حين وقوع الزلزال كثير
منهم لم يستطع العوده الى المنزل ليحضر
ثياب يمكن ان تقيه هذا البرد في هذه
الظروف الصعبه رغم كل هذا البرد هناك
اشخاص ما زالوا في هذا الجو المشحون
بالتوتر والخوف والقلق الكثير يفضلون
البقاء في العراء على الذهاب الى مراكز
الايواء اصلا يعني نعم حتى لو ارادوا
الذهاب مراكز اللواء تقريبا في مكتظه
باعداد والاف الاشخاص الذين التجاوا اليها
نعم ماذا عن المستشفيات زيدان
نعم يعني الخوف الان حتى الان يعني
معظم التصريحات الرسميه التركيه وانا اعرف
تلك المناطق جيدا يعني كونها هذه المناطق
هي متاخمه للحدود السوريه كان لنا مهمات
مع قناه العربيه في معظم هذه الولايات هذه
الولايات مقدمه بشكل جيد من القطاع الطبي
فيها قوي جدا لكن الخشيه اليوم زياده
اعداد المصابين ربما ستخلق ضغطا على هذه
المشافي الحكوميه المشاكل الحكوميه او حتى
المشاكل الخاصه التي تستقبل
المرضى وبالتالي اليوم حتى الان
14,400 مصاب اعتقد ان المشافي في الولايات
العاشره مجهزه بمشاف ضخمه يمكن ان تستوعب
هذا العدد لكن في حال زاد العدد وهذا ما
تخشاه كانت انقره ولذلك طلبت مساعدات طبيه
وهناك مشاكل ميدانيه قادمه من روسيا ومن
عده الدول هذه الاجراءات تريد انقره
اجراءات اضافيه احترازيه تحسبا لزياده
لزياده كبيره في اعداد المصابين او حتى
اصحاب الحالات الحرجه او حتى صهيب الاشخاص
الذين يقيمون في العراق هم عرضه للامراض
هؤلاء بحاجه ايضا لرعايه صحيه وتقديم
العلاج والدواء لكبار السن وللاطفال هذا
ايضا
مطلوب
لعشرات ومئات والاف الاشخاص ممن يحتاجون
هذه هذه العنايه الصحيه لذلك اليوم لا شك
ان القطاع الصحي
سيعاني من ضغط
بسبب
الازدحام او بسبب الاعداد الكبيره من
المصابين او حتى حالات الامراض بين
الاشخاص او المواطنين الذين يبيتون في
العراق او حتى في داخل مراكز اللواء نعم
نعم طيب زيدان سكتفي معك بهذا القدر حتى
الان على ان
توافينا بكل جديد او اي تحديث بالنسبه
لحصيله الزلزال طبعا واخر جهود الانقاذ
المستمره ايضا مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم اذا
في هذه
التغطيه اذن اعود اذكر الحصيله الان هي في
حدود 3700 قتيل في كل من تركيا
وسوريا
2379 قتيلا منهم في الاراضي التركيه حسب
التحديث الرسمي الذي نقله واعلنه نائب
الرئيس التركي بينما في سوريا ما زالت
الحصيله يعني
بانتظار المزيد من التاكيدات وهي مرشحه
اكيد للارتفاع بالنظر الى ان هناك مناطق
خاضعه للسيطره النظام او الحكومه السوريه
وهناك مناطق اخرى خاضعه للسيطره المعارضه
في حين ان منظمه الصحه العالميه كما
تابعنا قبل قليل في خبر عاجل
تتوقع ان تتضاعف هذه الحصيله ثمانيه مرات
او ثمانيه اضعف
طبعا تتعرض تركيا مشاهدينا باستمرار
لزلازل وهزات ارضيه حصدت ارواح الاف
الضحايا ودمرت المباني والبنى التحتيه
منذ عام 1500 شهدت تركيا نحو 23 زلزالا
مدمرا تجاوزت قوتها سبع درجات وفق تقديرات
علماء الجيولوجيا والمؤرخين زلزال ارزنجان
1939 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله تسعه تسبب
بمصرع 33 الف شخص واصابه نحو 100 الف
زلزال لاتيك
1943 بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله سته دمر
75% من ابنيه المنطقه واودى بحياه 2300
شخص
زلزال تشالديران بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله خمسه تسبب بمسرح ثلاثه الاف
وثمانمائه واربعين شخصا
[موسيقى]
زلزال بلغت قوته سبع درجات فاصله اثنين
تسبب بمسرع
894 شخصا
زلزالو فان 2011 بلغت قوته سبع درجات
فاصله اثنين ادى الى وفاه اكثر من 70 شخصا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر حركه
حاره كامله في حارة
بدنا نحكم العالم كلها تفرجهم
العالم كلها جايه
ربحكم دعكم احنا مالنا حدا مالنا غير رب
العالمين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على هذه الصور التي كنا نشاهد هي لفرق
الخوذ البيضاء في سوريا في المناطق
الخاضعه للمعارضه السوريه هي تحاول جاهده
يعني انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه ولكن اعدادها
تبقى قليله طبعا هناك مناطق سوريه كان
هناك شهادات ودعوات من قبل اناس في
المناطق السوريه خاصه الخاضعه
للمعارضه بانه لم يصل اليها احد ان هناك
بنايات مدمره ولكن لا فرق اغاثه وصلت
اليها اذا اظهرت صور من داخل احدى
المستشفيات في سوريا تحديدا في الاتارب
التابعه لحلب حيث يتلقى العلاج المصابون
جراء الزلزال المدمر نتابع الصور
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين الكرام مستمرون معكم في
تغطيه هذا الحدث الماساوي هذا الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب الاراضي التركيه والسوريه
كذلك بتحديد على المنطقه الحدوديه اذا
الحصيله حتى الان
3,700 قتيل في كل من سوريا وتركيا جراء
زلزلين بالاحرى شديدين الزلزال الاول بلغت
درجته
شدته 7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر بينما
الثاني الذي ضرب تركيا اذن بعد ساعات من
ذلك فبلغت شدته 7.5 درجات على سلم ريختر
نائب الرئيس التركي
اعلن قبل قليل الارتفاع حصيله الزلزال في
تركيا الى
2379 قتيلا و14,4
جريحا بحسب هذه الحصيله التي اعلنها فؤاد
اقطاي نائب الرئيس التركي وقال اقطاي انه
بعد اكثر من 20 ساعه من حصول الزلزال تم
انقاذ حوالي
7,840 ناجيا اخرجوا من بين الانقاض بينما
دمرت اربعه الاف وسبعمائه
وثمانون مبنى دمر بالكامل في الاراضي
التركيه طبعا اعود واذكر مشاهدينا بان
المنطقه تمر بمنخفض جوي
يعني شديد البروده ما يصعب اذن من جهود
الانقاذ اذا وكذلك يصعب كذلك من ظروف
الناجين كذلك الذين يمضون ليلتهم الاولى
اذا بعد
اذا هذا الزلزال نائب رئيس تركي قال انه
جراء التكفل او ايواء 52 الف شخص ولكن
ما افدى مراسلنا اذا قبل قليل الهزات
الارتداديه الكثيره هي ما تزال تخيف وترعب
الناس كذلك هناك من يفضل المبيت في العراء
رغم البرد الشديد هذه الليله وفي الحدائق
العامه خوفا من تكرار سيناريو الليله
الماضيه او الفجر
الماضي حيث يعني كانت الهزه الاولى الهزه
القويه
في الفجر في ساعات الفجر وطبعا استمرت
الهزه لحوالي ثلاثه دقائق يعني فكان هناك
دمار كبير هذا الدمار الذي نشاهده الان
طبعا واستمرار جهود الانقاذ
طيب معنى الان احمد مظهر سعد من غزه عنتاب
احمد اهلا بك معنا هلا نقلت لنا الصوره ما
الذي يحدث عندكم في غاز عنتاب هذه المنطقه
في جنوب تركيا من بين المناطق الاكثر
تضررا كذلك بهذا الزلزال اليوم
مساء الخير كل التحيه لكم
الوضع جدا الناس في حاله دور وخوش الناس
لا تنعم في المنازلها
في الصالات الرياضيه
والصالات العزاء والصلاه التي خصصت لهذه
الامور او في العرائم رغم البرد الشديد
كما
ذكرتها كل الذين
هم اماكن خارج بيوتهم لان رداس
يه مستمره وحتى منذ قليل تقريبا منذ ساعه
او ساعه وربع كان هناك
احتدادات ردات هديه جديده واخاف وقبل ذلك
ايضا بساعتين حصلت
القضيه بالنسبه للناس اصبحت مخيفه جدا وما
جرى في صباح امس هو حقيقه ما زال ماثلا في
من خلالهم ثم ما جرى ايضا في الساعه
الواحده والنصف من بعد الظهر ايضا من كبرى
ايضا افاقت الناس او حركت خوفهم من جديد
حقيقه هذه مساله اليوم يعني عاش الناس رغم
ان الثلوج في خارج البرد الشديد مع ذلك
الناس يفضلون البقاء خارج بيوتي احمد طبعا
غازي عنتاب من المناطق التركيه التي
يقطنها الكثير من السوريين الذين فروا من
ويلات الحرب واستقروا هناك الان لسنوات
طويله والان هم يعانون مره اخرى طبعا مع
مع الاتراك طبعا هناك من ويلات هذا
الزلزال كذلك هلا حدثني على موضوع
الوجود السوري هناك في في غازي عنتاب وكيف
هو طبعا
التعامل كذلك مع هذا الزلزال مع هذا
مع هذه الكارثه الماساويه
تعلمون ان مدينه غازي عنتاب هي ولايه
كبيره في جنوب وتوجه اليها السوريون منذ
تهجيرهم القصري باتجاه الشمال واتجاه
التركيه طبعا الان يتجاوز العديد السكان
السوريين الذين يخطون في غازي عنتاب 350
الف نسمه على الاقل هذا في المدينه لوحدها
ما عدا الارياف وبالتالي فان هناك كم كبير
من الاحياء هي مليئه بالسوريين وخاصه
الاحياء الفقيره الاحياء التي تجارها قليل
وهم ما يرغبون فيها سوريين وهنا كانت
الضامه الكبرى حيث ان الزلازل تؤثر في
الاحياء الفقيره في بيوت القديمه اكثر
بكثير من البيوت التي مبنيه على اسس جديده
علميه
وبالتالي فان الخساره الكبرى كانت بين
السوريين حقيقه وايضا من الاساس لكن نسبه
كبيره من السوريين قد لقوا حذفهم وكانوا
ضحايا
طبعا ليس فقط انا اقول هذا الكلام في عين
تاب ايضا في مرعش كهرباء مرعش وايضا في
انطاكيا حيث وايضا في اوروبا حيث يتواجد
السوريون في احياء شعبيه قصيره وهي قديمه
تتحمل الزلازل الكبرى نعم ارجو ان تبقى
معي احمد في هذه التغطيه لدينا عاجل جديد
موقف امريكي الان واضح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلانكا يبدو انه اتصل مع
نظره التركي
واكد ان الاستجابه الامريكيه
الاوليه للمساعدات اذا انطلقت
نعرف اكثر من مراسلتنا ناديه البلبيسي من
واشنطن مكالمه هاتفيه اذا بين بلينكن
وتشوي شغله
يبدو ان هناك تحرك الرغم التباين السياسي
ناديا بين انقره واشنطن
بدون ادنى شك الاداره الامريكيه تتعامل مع
هذه الكارثه على انها كارثه انسانيه
بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي قبل قليل اصدرت
وزاره الخارجيه هذا البيان التي اكدت فيه
على ان الوزير بلينكن اتصل بنظيره التركي
واعرب عن اسفه للضحايا لحجم هذا الدمار
الذي
بسبب زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وقال
بان الولايات المتحده ستقدم كل مساعده
ممكنه طبعا هذه المساعده تحدث عنها قبل
ساعات تقريبا البيت الابيض وقال بانه
سيرسل فرق انقاذ هو بحث تتكون من فرقتين
بالتحديد 79 عامل اغاثه كما تعرف الولايات
المتحده لديها خبره في التعاون التعامل مع
الكوارث الطبيعيه وخصوصا الزلازل في ولايه
كاليفورنيا زلزال الشهير ضرب فرانسيسكو
لديها ربما الالات التي يمكن الكشف فيها
عن
تحدي يعني هذا السؤال كان يشغل بالي نعم
بالنظر الى شاهدتي اكيد صور يعني المرعبه
للمباني التي سويت بالارض يعني امام
الكاميرات يعني وهناك احياء باكملها
بنايات بعده طوابق باتت ركاما على الارض
هل الامريكيون لديهم تقنيات حديثه ربما
لانه المهمه تبدو صعبه جدا وشاقه منظمه
الصحه العالميه تتوقع ان يتضاعف عدد ضحايا
ثمان مرات على الاقل هل الامريكيون لديهم
تكنولوجيا اعلى متفوقه اكثر في هكذا كوارث
نعم لدي مع التكنولوجيا لديهما الادوات
التي تمكن عمال الانقاذ من الكشف عن
الاشخاص المدفونين تحت الانقاذ يعني
بالنهايه نحن نتحدث عن فارق ربما دقائق
بين الحياه والموت حتى لواشن تدرك حجم هذه
الكارثه وحجم السرعه التي يجب ان تتحرك
بها ومن هنا كنت اتحدث سابقا عن حاله
استنفار هي تضم وزاره الدفاع التي بامكانه
ان ترسل باسرع وقت ممكن عن طريق جسر جوي
كل هذه المعدات وفرق الانقاذ لتصل في
الوقت المناسب
لمساعده المنكوبين بالتحديد الاداره لديها
مواقف مختلفه مع انقره مع انقره لكنها
تعتبر تركيا دوله حليفه ضمن حلف شمال
الاطلسي وبالتالي هي مستعده من ناحيه
انسانيه ان تقدم كل هذه المساعدات ليس فقط
لتركيا لكن ايضا لسوريا رغم ان سوريا تخضع
لعقوبات امريكيه شديده جدا
هذه النقطه يحرم على اي جهه التعامل مع
سوريا ممتاز كيف يمكن تجاوز يعني هذه
العقوبات ناديه خاصه انه هناك يعني نداءات
استغاثه خاصه من مناطق المعارضه السوريه
بانه لا احد ذهب اليهم هناك فقط مجموعات
القوه البيضاء التي تقوم بالانقاذ
فكيف يمكن تجاوز مساله العقوبات وعدم
التعاون مع النظام السوري في ظل هذه
الكارثه الانسانيه
في الواقع وزاره الخارجيه قالت انها هي
غير مضطره للتعامل مع النظام السوري هي
ترى بان النظام السوري كان مسؤول عن قتل
مئات الالاف من السوريين وتهجير الملايين
منهم وبالتالي هي مستعده للعمل مع كل
المنظمات الانسانيه
والغير حكوميه التي تعمل في الشمال السوري
بالتحديد في المناطق الغير خاضعه للنظام
لكن كما تعرف صهيب حتى تركيا نفسها كانت
تعرقل ادخال بعض المساعدات عن طريق
المعابر المشتركه بين الحدود السوريه
والحدود التركيه في ترامب في فتره معينه
لذا هي حفله اليوم تركيا على فتح هذه
الحدود
والتسهيل من دخول عمال الاغاثه لكن كما
تعرف هناك بيروقراطيه عن التعامل مع دوله
مثل تركيا سيكون سهل وخصوصا وانها دوله
حليفه للولايات المتحده وعضو في حلف النات
ولكن بالنسبه لسوريا الوضع معقد كثير
وبالتالي للاسف ستكون هناك معاناه انسانيه
نهائيه حتى وصول هذه الطواقم للمحتاجين
واولئك المنكوبين الذين البعض منهم لا
يزال تحت الانقاض لكن مره اخرى واشنطن
تقول بانها مستعده لتقديم كل هذه
المساعدات وباسرع وقت ممكن سواء كانت
تركيا او السوريين في داخل سوريا طبعا
امامي الان التفاصيل المحادثه وما قاله
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه قال انه
بلنكن ابلغ نظيره التركي بان ما عليه فقط
ان يرفع سماعه الهاتف
ويخبرنا بما يمكن ان تفعله الولايات
المتحده لتقديم المساعده بعد هذا الزلزال
القوي
يعني هل يعني هذا هذه اللغه او هذه
العباره معناها انه هناك استعداد كامل
لتلبيه كل الطلبات التركيه امهم يعني ما
معناه انه الاداره الامريكيه تنتظر
طلبا من من تركيا ناديه هلا فسرتي لنا
اكثر لو سمحتي
مقدمين في هذه المناطق بالتحديد طبعا يعني
معروف عندما يكون هناك زلزال ماذا يمكن ان
يقدم ليس فقط هي طلبات محدده من الحكومه
التركيه لكن كما قال بلينك بالفعل بانه
بامكان وزير الخارجيه ان يرفع الهاتف وان
يتصل بواشنطن وهو مستعد ان يقدم اكثر مما
قدمته واشنطن حتى الان وهو الالتزام سواء
كان في طريقها الى انقره الان او الى
تركيا عفوا او الى المناطق المنكوبه لكن
ايضا هناك اتصال هاتفي بين رئيس بايدن
والرئيس اردوغان لتاكيد الدعم الامريكي
وايصال ما تحتاجه طبعا ليس فقط نتحدث عن
فرق الاغاثه نتحدث عن ادويه نتحدث عن غذاء
نتحدث عن خيم ربما تاوي اولئك المهجرين
الذين تهجروا مرتين وخصوصا نتحدث عن
السوريين كما ذكرت الموجودين سواء كانوا
في جنوب تركيا او في داخل الشمال السوري
عباره هذه يرفع سماعه الهاتف ويخبرنا بما
يحتاجه لان الوقت عامل حاسم في هذه
الكارثه يعني اي تاخر يعني يمكن ان يؤدي
الى هلاك شخص عالق تحت الانقاض يعني
المساله اذا مرت اكثر
ايام معدودات لا يمكن للشخص ان يصمد اكثر
هؤلاء العالقون تحت الانقاض وهذا يدفعني
كي اسال ماذا نعرف عن متى تبدا المساعدات
او الفرق الامريكيه بالتوجه الى تركيا
وتقديم المساعده كذلك للسوريين في شمال
سوريا
انا احاول ان احصل على يعني تفاصيل بالفعل
سواء كانت من وزاره الخارجيه او من
ربما هو المناط اكثر بهذه المهام لسرعه
ربما ان شاء الجسر الجوي وايصال كل فرق
الانقاذ لكن اعتقد بانها بدات بالفعل
بالوصول الى تركيا يعني نتحدث عن يوم
تقريبا منذ ان بدا
الاعلان عن هذا الزلزال وكانت هناك
الاخبار العاجله ليله امس بتوقيت واشنطن
وطبعا تم اخبار البيت الابيض وزاره
الخارجيه والتحرك كان سريعا يعني كما ذكرت
في السؤال السابق بانه لا ينتظر ماذا تريد
تركيا الولايات المتحده بامكانها ان ترسل
كلها هؤلاء الخبراء الفرق المتخصصه هذه
الالات الحديثه التي يمكن ان تكشف ان
تستمع الى اصوات ربما تناشد بالانقاذ من
تحت الانقاذ وبالتالي اعتقد باننا سنحصل
على تفاصيل اكثر اكثر لاحقا نعم لكن اعتقد
بانه عمليه ايصال هذه الفرق الى تركيا على
الاقل بدات الى سوريا امر معقد بسبب طبعا
كما تعرف عدم التعامل مع النظام وعدم خضوع
هذه الاراضي اللي هي شمال سوريا الى سيطره
القوات الامريكيه او قوات محايده هي تعمل
من خلال وجود عسكري امريكي لكن ليس وجود
مدني او مساعده مباشره وبالتالي هي تعتمد
على الامم المتحده وعلى المنظمات
الانسانيه غير الحكوميه التي تعمل في
الشمال السوري نعم شكرا جزيلا لك حتى الان
ناديه نتواصل تباعا ضمن هذه هي التغطيه
المستمره ايضا مشاهدينا مره اخرى الحصيله
الان 3700 قتيل في كل من تركيا وسوريا
جراء هذا الزلزلين المدمرين حوالي 20 ساعه
مرت الان بعد اول زلزال وكانت شدته 7.8
درجات على مقياس ريختر بعده بساعات كان
هناك زلزال اخر
بقوه
7.5 درجات على مقياس
هاتين الهزتين طبعا
العشرات ان لم تكن المئات حوالي اكثر من
200 هزه ارتداديه حتى الان جهود الانقاذ
ما تزال مستمره وطبعا هناك حمله تضامن
دوليه طبعا مع ضحايا هذا الزلزال اذا اخر
المواقف من الولايات المتحده كما تبعنا مع
مراسلتنا لنعود ونتابع المشهد اكثر في
غازي عنتاب في جنوب تركيا معك احمد مظهر
اذا كنت تسمعني احمد
اسالك كذلك على مساله التكفل بالناجين
الان كيف يتم تاطير او التكفل بالناجين في
هذه الليله الاولى بعد هذه الكارثه
لذلك هناك اهتمام جدي مبدئيا من اجل
ايواءهم في اماكن عامه كما قلت انا في
بدايه حديث ان هناك صلاه رياضيه مفتوحه
وتعج
الناجحين او الفريق من من تحت الانقاض ومن
الزلازل وايضا صاله التعديه وايضا كل ما
هو موجود لصالح البلديات مثل مفتوحه
ومهيا يعني هذه مساله مهمه وكان المساله
فعلا هناك دراسه منذ فتره لتهديد اماكن
عامه
بالتدفئه بالغذاء بكل انواع الصحه
المطلوبه هذه مساله واضحه تمام العالم
وانا الان يعني اعيش ضمن احد هذه الصلاه
واعرف تماما ماذا يعني اهتمام
الالاف الناس الذين يعيشون بهذه الصلاه
حقيقه هناك اهتمام لا شك في ذلك وهي
مساله مك
دوسه اذكر
انه جرى تمرين تدريبي لسلازم في تركيا شمل
المعظمة لولايه الجنوبيه وبالتالي يعني
اليوم هناك اهتمام نعم وهناك رعايه بقدر
ما يستطيعون طبعا طبعا هذا لا يعني انه
ليسوا بحاجه الى مساعده بالتاكيد
الدمار كبير يعني اي مساعده يمكن ان
تنقذ حياه طيب
استوقفتني اليوم شهاده
احد الناجين
ذكرت انه لحظه الزلزال الاول يعني شعرت
وكانها نهايه العالم احمد انت كيف عايشت
تلك اللحظه كيف عايشت لحظه الزلزال مع
العلم انه استمر قيل انه استمر لحوالي
ثلاث دقائق
في الحقيقه يعني طبعا نحن مر علينا سواء
كان في سوريا سابقا او في تركيا حاليا
ولكن لم يكن اي زلزال بمن هذا المستوى
هو مخيف جدا ومفشع وايضا جاء في لحظه
فارقه بمعنى الناس نائمون الساعه اربعه
عشر دقيقه بالضبط افقنا على
الحاله مرعبه البيت يهز كله الجدران تطرق
في بعضها شبيك تطرق الاشياء المعلقه تحدث
تكسير زجاج شغله غير مسبوقه يعني الانسان
لا يلوي على شيء ماذا يفعل يعني كيف يمكن
ان يحمل اي شيء وينزل بهذا البرد للشارع
اولاده كيف ينقذهم كيف يعني كانت فظيعه
استطاع الناس فعلا في لحظات وجدنا الناس
ملئه بالشوارع والساحات كلها فيها عز
البرد وبالتاكيد يعني كل من نزل لم يستطع
ان ياخذ حتى معه شيء يدفئه او شمسيه تقيه
المطر والثلج الموجود كان متساقط في
لحصتها بالتاكيد حاله مخيفه لا شك وحاله
سعر لا نتمناها لاي انسان وهذه المساله
طبعا هي بالتاكيد من نتاج ايضا واقع مخيف
البعاشه السوري عموما الذين اتوا بي الى
الشمال الى تركيا من خلال القصف والبراميل
والتماوي الذي مورث بالزلازل طيب نعم
للاسف احمد طيب ولكن هل شاهدت يعني اي
جهود
لمساعده الناس يعني ان كان كما ذكرت انه
البرد شديد الان يعني
والامضاء هذه الليله صعب جدا على كل الصعد
هل هناك توزيع لبطانيات توزيع لمعاطف اي
شيء يمكن ان يساعد الناس يعني حتى الان
انا لم الحظ ذلك انا لاحظت ان هناك اماكن
ايواء مجهزه مكيفه مثلا يعني امام هذا
قضايا اساسيه نعم
وبالتالي من كل من اتى يحمل البطانيته معه
او يحمل اشيائه الخاصه معهم يعني هذا الذي
لاحظته في الصلاه واماكن تواجد النازحين
او اللاجئين للحاربين من الزلازل يعني
ولكن بالتاكيد
القضايا مساعدات ستصل ان صح التعبير فيما
لو قال امد الناس بالتاكيد سيؤمن لهم اكثر
من ذلك لكن انا اعود القول انه يعني لا
يجب ان يكون هناك انتظار لدى الامريكان
ولا سواهم لان يتصل وزير الخارجيه التركيه
ليطلب منهم مساعدات
على الاطلاق هناك ناس لا زالوا حتى اللحظه
هم تحت الانقاض حتى اللحظه في كثير من
الولايات في الجنوب التركي هي من تحت
الانقاذ وغير قادر احد على انفازهم لانه
ليس
هناك قاضيه وليس هناك طواقم قادره او
كافيه على الاقل يعني موجوده وتتحرك وتعمل
لكنها غير كافيه لان حجم الدمار كبير
الابنيه يعني هناك بناء اليوم شاهدته على
الارض بناء كامل على الارض وهو طبعا لان
الغناء قديم وحقيقه حتى رفع الانقاذ مساله
غايه في الصعوبه وليس هناك امكانيات تقنيه
حديثه يمكن ان ترفعها بسرعه وهذا ما حصل
في اكثر من ولايه ليس فقط في عنتاب في
مرعش حتى اللحظه يتكون الناس ويحاولوا رفع
الانقراض من اوسع بكاملها تحت الاقامه
احمد اعذرني وقت انتهى ولكن في عجاله هل
لديك اي معلومات عن الوضع في سوريا
الوضع في سوريا اولا الشمال السوري وضعه
صعب جدا في مناطق النظام هذا النظام
المجرم يرفق اي مساعده عفريتيه
لمناطق ويعتبرها خارجه عليه او
خارج عظام وبالتالي لا مساعدات لا تعاون
مع جهاز تركيا علما انه كان يفترض ان يكون
هناك تعاون في وقت نرى فيه ان هناك علاقات
امنيه مستمره بين تركيا والنظام السوري
فلماذا لا يكون هل اليوم هذا التعاون فيه
طيب هل هناك يعني اي مساعدات تركيه
ذهبت الى المناطق السوريه الخاضعه لسيطره
المعارضه
هناك مساعدات دائما سنفي هناك مؤسسات
ومنظمات تركيا تقدم مساعدات وبالتاكيد في
هذا الظرف الصعب هي تقوم بهذه المساعدات
لكن انا باعتقادي ايضا
هناك صحيح
كارثه كبيره جدا نعم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
احمد مظهر سعد وانت الصحفي كنت معنا من
غازي عنتاب
وخلال زيارته مدينه ملطيه بشرق تركيا وهي
احدى المدن التي تضررت بشده من الزلزال
اعلن وزير التعليم التركي محمود اوزر عن
اغلاق جميع المدارس في البلاد حتى الثالثه
عشر من الشهر الجاري
المناخ والظروف الحاليه في جميع انحاء
تركيا ومن اجل مواصله الاعمال في مناطق
الزلزال بشكل اكثر هدوءا ليس فقط في مناطق
الزلزال بل في جميع انحاء البلاد نعلن عن
عطله في جميع مدارس تركيا حتى الثالث عشر
من فبراير
احنا مرتاحين
يلا يا حجه يلا يلا
من اسطنبول ينضم الينا الكاتب الصحفيه
فراس رضوان اوغلو استاذ فراس اهلا بك معنا
غير الحصيله الاخيره التي اعلنها
هل هناك اي معلومات جديده بخصوص ضحايا
الزلزال وكذلك جهود الانقاذ حتى الان
يعني حتى الان لم ترد حصيله جديده
الى الارقام سواء للجرحى او القتلى لكن
يعني في هذا الموضوع لحتى
خبر جديد لكن ربما هناك بعض الاخبار
الاخرى مثلا قررت خطوط الجويه التركيه ان
ترصد يعني او البطاقات الطيران الى تلك
المناطق فيما يعادل 100 ليره تركيه اي
ثمانيه دولارات او تسعه دولارات بهذا
القدر لمن يريد السفر الى هناك ايضا يعني
وجسر كامل بين الخطوط الجويه
باتجاه تلك المناطق دون التوقف طبعا اضنه
ديار بكر اليزار تلك المدن الثلاثه التي
تكلمت عنها اضافه الى يعني الهزتين
الارضتين واحده قبل تقريبا قبل ممكن نقول
نفسها قبل تقريبا خمسين دقيقه كانت قويه
قبل تقريبا اقل من ساعتين
فقط في مرعش والهزتين في مرعش واحده خمسه
فاصل اربعه وواحده خمسه فاصله صفر بينهما
تقريبا اقل من ساعه
لم يذكر ان اي يعني
ارتدادات لها سيئه او مباني او ما شابه
ذلك لكن في نفس المكان هزتين في في نفس
الوقت طبعا يعني حتى الان لا يوجد اي
تعديل في في كثير من الاخبار فقط يعني
اعلنته
الخطوط الجويه التركيه ننتظر التعديلات
القادمه نعود البيانات الصحفيه التي يمكن
ان تصدر خصوصا نحن في الليل
لا نعلم ما هي النتائج يعني بمعنى يبطئ
نوعا ما عمليه الانقاذ نعم طيب
هذا بالنسبه لتركي هل لديكم اي معطيات
فيما يتعلق بجهود الانقاذ في سوريا في
شمال سوريا على الحدود مع مع تركيا وهل
هناك اي مساعدات تذهب بذلك الاتجاه
حتى الان لم يصدر اي بيان او تصريح في هذا
السياق نحن نعلم ان هناك منظمات ومؤسسات
مدنيه تركيه موجوده في تلك المناطق منذ
قبل يعني بالتاكيد هي لديها تنسيق كامل مع
المؤسسه الام في في تركيا لكن لم يصدر اي
بيان او اي تصريح لا من الداخل السوري تلك
المنظمات ولا حتى من الافات او الهلال
الاحمر او ما شابه ذلك من هنا بانه ارسل
او مساعده
اظن يعني
الوقع جلل ولذلك يعني الكل ربما
يسعى الى قدر الاستطاعه الاستيعاب ما يمكن
استيعابه في هذه المرحله ربما لو زادت عدد
الفرق لانقاذ القادمه من الخارج التركي قد
نوعا ما تسهل ارسال او مساعدات الى
الشمال السوري لكن
لا استطيع ان
اي معلومه لم تذكر حتى الان بشكل
رسمينا عنها حتى من الشمال السوري ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك أستاذ فراس ارجو ان تبقى
معنا طبعا نحن يعني
ابقيناك معنا لساعات طوال ارجو ان تتحملنا
لا يمكن التنبؤ مشاهدينا بالزلازل قبل
حدوثها لاجل ذلك يصعب تفادي تداعيات
الزلزال الخطره والتي تكون احيانا مدمره
حسب قوته بمقياس ريختر لنلقي مع نظره عامه
حول كيفيه حصول الزلازل يعرف الزلزال
مشاهدينا بانه اهتزاز ارضي مفاجئ ينتج عن
الحركه المستمره للصفائح التكتونيه والتي
تسبب تراكم الضغط على طبقات الصخور على
جانبي الصدوع الواقعه بين الصفائح مما
يؤدي الى تكسر الكتل الصخريه وانزلاقها
فوق بعضها وبالتالي اطلاق الطاقه المخزنه
في القشره الارضيه في حركه مفاجئه ينتج
عنها موجات
طاقه زلزاليه تنتشر عبر صخور الارض لتصل
الى السطح مما يتسبب بحدوث الاهتزازات
الزلزاليه تتعدد الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصول
الزلازل لتشمل الهزات التكتونيه للطبقات
التكتونيه طبعا التي تعد الاكثر شيوعا
وهنا يحدث انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع
المحيط لينقسم الى عدد من الاجزاء او
الصفائح الصلبه التي تتراوح سماكتتها ما
بين 100 ومئه وخمسين كيلومترا لتتحرك
بعدها حركه مستمره فوق طبقه الغلاف الموري
التي تقع تحت القشره الارضيه هناك ايضا
الزلازل البركانيه التي تحدث بسبب
البراكين النشطه ولكنها ليست بقوه الزلازل
التكتونيه وغالبا ما تحدث بالقرب من سطح
الارض ولذلك يتم الشعور بها فقط بالقرب من
نقطه منشا الزلزال يعقبه حدوث الزلازل
العديد من الاحداث والاثار التي قد تكون
مدمره ويمكن ان تتخذ اشكالا متعدده منها
الان الفيضانات والحرائق وسيل التربه
وتسونامي واليكم مشاهدينا بعض النصائح في
حاله وقوع الزلزال وبعد وقوعه كذلك وفق
الخبراء
ابرز الزلازل المميته حول العالم في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس عام 2021
من ابريل عام 2016
الاكوادور زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه ومقتل 650
شخصا
في الخامس والعشرين من ابريل عام 2015
نيبال زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه وتسبب بمقتل
تسعه الاف شخص
الحادي عشر من مارس عام 2011 اليابان
زلزال مدمر بقوه تسع درجات خلف عشرين الفا
بين قتيل ومفقود السادس والعشرون من
ديسمبر عام 2003 ايران زلزال بقوه 6.6
درجه اسفر عن مقتل 31 الف شخص
[موسيقى]
تركيا مشاهدينا تقع على عده خطوط صدع
رئيسيه ما يجعلها منطقه النشطه للزلازل
نتابع
الهزات الارضيه ظواهر متكرره الحدوث في
تركيا تعود الى وقوع معظم اجزاء تركيا على
الصفيحه الاناضليه التي تتموضع بين
الصفيحه الاوراسيه التي تمثل نسبيا قشره
غير قابله للحركه والصفيحه العربيه التي
تتجه شمالا بمعدل بوصه واحده تقريبا سنويا
يؤدي هذا الى ضغط تركيا التي تقف على عده
خطوط السطع اكثر خطوط الصدع تدميرا في
تركيا هو خط الصدع شمالي الاناضول حيث
تلتقي صفيحه الاناضول والاوراسيا هذا
ويمتد خط الصدع شمال الاناضول من جنوب
اسطنبول مباشره على طول الطريق الى شمال
شرق تركيا كذلك يمتد خط صدع شرق الاناضول
حوالي 650 كيلومترا من مرتفعات شرق تركيا
الى البحر المتوسط حيث يتجه جنوبا ويلتقي
في النهايه مع الصدع الكبير الذي يفصل بين
الصفائح الافريقيه والعربيه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
عد الى ضيف الاستاذ فراس رضوان اوغلو من
اسطنبول استاد فراس طبعا هذا الزلزال
المدمر وهذه الكارثه
اتت في زمن السوشيال ميديا الجمعيه يتحدث
الجميع يتنبا الجميع يحذر وكان هناك حديث
على انتشار الاشاعات بشكل كبير جدا وعلى
التحذيرات رغم تاكيد الخبراء الجيولوجيين
بانه لا يمكن التنبؤ بحدوث الزلازل
دعني اسالك عن هذا الموضوع بالذات مساله
الاشاعات الان ودور السوشيال ميديا في
هكذا كوارث كيف تراه
نعم يعني حتى قبل اظن عده ساعات كان
للداخليه تصريح بان هناك 13 موقعا مزيفا
يصدر تصريح واخبار غير حقيقيه وغير كاذبه
لذلك بعدها خرج السيد فؤاد اقطاي لاعب
الرئيس وقال يرجى اخذ فقط المعلومات من
الافات نفسها وليس من اي مكان اخر اذن نعم
للاسف هذا موجود لاعتبارات متعدده يعني
سواء سياسيه سؤال ماليه او احتياليه في
هذا استسمحك استاذ فراس فقط اسمحلي لانه
كنا نتابع على مدار هذه التغطيه الموقف
الامريكي طبعا من الزلزال ومساعده تركيا
بالنظر طبعا الى الخلاف السياسي بين
الدولتين ولكن طبعا هناك تجاوز لهذه
النقطه امام هذه الكارثه الانسانيه الان
يبدو ان هناك اتصال هاتفي فيما بين الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ونظيره التركيه رجب طيب
اردوغان البيت الابيض الان يؤكد ان بايدن
يؤكد لاردوغان هاتفي استعداد امريكا لدعم
تركيا في مواجهه اثار الزلزال قبل هذا
الاتصال كان هناك اتصال من انطوني بلينكل
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع نظيره التركي
اوغلو اكد فيه طبعا استعداد الولايات
المتحده لدينا ضيفي اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
استاذ فراس انت باقي معنا في هذه التغطيه
ولكن هذه الساعه انتهت مشاهدينا اخر حصيره
لدينا 3700 قتيل بين تركيا وسوريا في هذا
الزلزال المدمر التغطيه مستمره على
العربيه الزميل ابراهيم بدر يلقاكم اذا
ويتابع معكم اخر التطورات في الساعه
المواليه اليك ابراهيم